what's up y'all will take clan in the
building yes sir we're here doing the
wires autocomplete interview that's
right what's up inspector dead you gob
you got shemail i read sir Jesus Christ
some weird ass question where the wait
bill avenges yes is little clan still
together yes their memories never broke
up once a clan is a family that's right
you know even even if I don't like them
today I still gotta love him I love me
tomorrow I'm sad
loot a clan east to west coast
o-hisa west coast be snowy sweep global
baby we blow okay
it's a clan from Staten Island I'm from
Brooklyn
I'm from Oakland - I was born in
Brooklyn he's brought a book that I was
born in the Bronx will be migrated to
Staten Island wu-tang name I guess the
Klan the music started the next joint is
Wu Tang Clan gangster rap we got some
gang just talked about but but now as
far as gangster rap nah man we talk a
lot of stuff we make streets popular his
logic in the wu-tang clan man I used to
be on the road with me back in the days
turned it did a couple of shows before
he was you might get a set skate a
little bit though you got to test out
let somebody know you live in school
you'ii like that what does wu-tang clan
baby don't say cleansing Mimi's
Brotherhood
what does wu-tang clan rap about what we
rap about we rap about every day
everything under the Sun you can think
about we rap about science Sun was the
square miles of planet Earth
ladies see a tizzy ABC piano here feel
it too it does contain clans stand for
loyalty is royalty gotta stand for
something that you fall for anything
right mmm things never really about yeah
bridging allottee stand loot ain't
cleaned under quit were they talking
about
well it does wu-tang clan Guadalupe to
me I never knew that she grabbed me
that's what we got no answer for Vanessa
I never know what that meant my damn
self I don't know what that means
I think it's well reserved made the beat
in the air just so I'm saying it sounded
like like a Flintstone II type of thing
hmm yeah I can't remember but that's why
we did the video looking like the
Flintstones and stuff when I can't
remember out there was dinosaurs and
ninjas in the video and we was out of
the desert it was 150 degrees on tan
clan that's a crazy one I feel like we
all form together well you know RZA was
the main factor you know he's a the
comment he's like the the main magnet
yeah I think ghosts actually took the
name from the blue tank movies and made
like if something was cool it was hot
it's moot anger that's whoo yeah yeah
yeah oh this is warm the clan form to
think my clan
that's a risk who is the leader of the
wu-tang clan
hmm yeah we all kind of lead ourselves
and by an agreement of collective minds
coming together as one
you know we all say what we're gonna do
yeah there's no like one one leader but
if you had to look at a head I mean you
would have to do that to visit snuggy
that's a tablet it is who is Wu Tang
Clan now who will we nowadays it 800
okay I mean I think we liked and we
liked the black Rolling Stones or the
Beatles or some say it was the best
boots and Klan member now if it comes to
down to a show anybody can be MVP that
night yeah you know I mean anybody can
be most valuable player when it comes to
a selfie but we have nights where ghosts
might kill it enough night you know you
just might kill it math whoever you G
and it goes on and on why did st. Claire
for all who Tang William predictable
talent and naturally gifted that's where
they gifted natural game saying is also
the best sports style of kungfu so being
that we say that our lyrics and our
words are like sports you know and we we
saw ourselves as the best MC so we
decided to call ourself insane clintus
or Stalin Brahman why is Wu Tang Clan
the best I don't like to hear it from
other people you know I mean if for one
reason that I would say I don't think it
is a group with our size and magnitude
that made a that success hop that made
it this far you know that we've taken it
to I saw like it will you say I'll still
I'll still be here and still be here
yeah well something we include everybody
to like wu-tang man we like I went to
Russia Croatia I've been all over the
world that people are they more wu-tang
than I am dealer
wise wu-tang clan in Portland somebody
got it somebody got a later blueprint
down to how to do this
you know the young generation is growing
up they're doing what they do they do
anything but you know you want to keep
this hip-hop and keep the spirit of the
craft alive you know I think we're
important I think you need to study us
and look up the history and kind of like
know like if you're a young football
player you going back if you study in
Jerry Rice and you're looking at the
Great's of the game how did you be
greater nothing you could say here take
a peel off our poster - why don't we
chain clam break up we never broke up
sons it was always design that we would
do what we do solo wise and you know we
all you know stars and our own right
individually clan only make one out what
we must be about five out of D&D chamber
WI flag ever who take whatever they died
better tomorrow eight diagrams six or
six what is won't same class Wow no is
no is no father to the stab baby I'm
sorry
it's a formless formation yes right
that's water it's just the energy yeah
we I think we don't have a style we have
a energy it is the best boots and clinic
out I take the first one me personally
because I won that set it off yeah I say
between that and forever yeah yeah what
is the wu-tang clan's that song don't
want is definitely cool Gambino's best
one day is Rumble other day is do that
dance next day for me I go back listen
to my hypodermics yeah it's issues yes
as Mooney is moody whatever moving women
though what is the wu-tang clan's logo
logo whatever what is it uh what's the
eagle a yellow
you and an eagle like some type of some
type of bird of some sort
DJ mathematics man he he put that one
together that's right put his foot in it
put his ankle in that one member will
turn clan on our podcast radio people
around the world celebrate Wednesday as
officially whoo day it's okay to wear
any wu-tang gear you got kick anyone
saying rhymes you know post up and evil
I love that I was wu-tang clan formed
how was it follows it form Wow Wow by a
common interest friendship camaraderie
Brotherhood you know a like be like
y'all he liked tracks yeah he had the
sanctuary for us to get away from all
that crazy going through you know we
want to get away from all the drugs and
the guns and the police you go to his
house and it was just a calm spot for us
to be in you know how did the wu-tang
clan get their name but your Shaolin vs.
matang I believe it is original movie
where they mentioned the wu-tang wu-tang
wanted to break away from Shaolin Temple
you know Shaolin with a mountain
Buddha's name be praised and who Tang
goes where I go
Tang was like the rebels yeah we're not
turning out of the sheet you want to go
out there handle those deals if you know
they rebelled against the temple and
then we kicked out so we kind of took
that approach to say like that's how he
was in the industry you know like we
were two outcasts of industry what is
the wu-tang clan's most popular song
dream is a very popular song right I
mean but then you got you know other
songs like Jodeci from you know with
peace of rain ghosts cream and trying
for one of them I would say like yeah
gravel pit as popular - now there's a
weird
grab a piss we even a saw like met that
man you know I mean very popular very
popular shimmy shimmy shimmy shimmy
oh so Brooklyn zoo you know it's like
I'd like to say the first album how many
members Tang Clan have hey I'm some over
80 right I added not betting on like Bo
habitat and sin so then we got like
street life right right Red Menace never
Lilly I mean even nods you know I mean
brothers you know that came and out in
our circle and really rep you know since
the beginning man it's like family's
family no I mean it's probably a strong
thirteen original like day one people of
us Busta Rhymes can't forget busted me
oh yeah this then the family's crazy
right booted a family of that Dave
Chappelle is blue tang Tang Clan
hand-signs
w it was just you know like your wings
take white we used to do this at the
show make everybody I could flap your
wings it not know West Coast don't took
that yeah west coast dr. W like that so
we just try to make our own little thing
like there's an emoji that does this one
right here so this is kind of you know
what's the emoji and this was the
original we show the crab chuck it she
wagon well that was it Google smuggled
in a pool know you're dealing we this is
25 years later it's a whole different
generation of listeners so you know I
don't think any question is a bad
question of question is for people who
wants to know what a nose yeah I think
that was the 9 to 15 days back